une ambiance rouge un solo de guitare
des textes évoquant le chaos
inspiré d'une série de photos prises par
richard du mort en 1994 au matin de
l'incendié du parlement de bretagne
les deux artistes olivier mellano et
richard dumas ont créé une improvisation
musicale abstraite ou les écrits sont
les seules matières de l'oeuvre on
connaît les éléments qui avaient
encerclé le texte ces bouts de textes
mais richard pour les prendre n'importe
quel moment et on est vraiment on écoute
l'un et l'autre est en réaction par
rapport à ce qui se passe à ce moment là
donc on fait on n'a jamais fait deux
fois pareil c'est la première fois qu'on
fait cette manière qu avec la guitare on
s'est dit on fonce et puis on verra
comment ça se passe il faut sentir le
moment telles paroles raisonnée ou
entrer en résonance en armure en
résonance pour leur troisième
représentation devant un public les
artistes ont voulu également adapté en
temps réel cette improvisation face aux
réactions de la salle on prend
l'ensemble des gens qui sont là on sait
ce qui
qui voilà qui est là et on n'est pas
qu'on n'est pas coupé de ces gens n'ont
pas coupé des gens que nous sommes se
forment un tout une recette qui a
fonctionné auprès de la quarantaine de
spectateurs présents à la commanderie
des templiers performance
c'est ici au niveau contemplatif je
dirais ça mais les mots l'essence
la musique et le sens des mots moi je
pars moment j'entendais pas tout mais
des mots comme ça qui surgissaient comme
dans un rêve parfois comme dans un
cauchemar
le rendez-vous à clôturer l'exposition
perception et illusions installé pendant
quatre mois et l'encours le public lui
en redemande
[Applaudissements]